[موسيقى]
التي بدات الماضي عن سقوط سته هنا مخيم
عين الحلوه نعرف تاريخ اول الرصاصه اطلقت
لكن لا احد يعلم متى ستكون اخر رصاصه لعنا
حاتين بالليالي شو بعد بدهم يحطونا على
البحر
ولا يحرقونا بالمخيم يحاسبنا ويحرقونا
بنرتاح
فنيه نالت شهره عالميه ابرزهم الفنان
الراحل ماجد علي
انا ابن مخيم عين الحلوه يصف كثيرون
المخيم بانه عاصمه الشتات الفلسطيني
وفلسطين المصغره فهنا السلطه تتولاها
فصائل مسلحه مختلفه في التوجه السياسي
والعقائدي ورغم صغر هذه الرقعه فانها
منقسمه جغرافيا باختلاف الجهات المسيطره
عليها والشيء الذي يوحد سكان هذا المخيم
هو المعاناه المستمره
جنوب شرقي مدينه صيدا اللبنانيه في هذه
النقطه تحديدا يقع مخيم عين الحلوه اسس
بعد وقت قصير من نكبه الفلسطينيين عام
1948 على بقعه لا تتجاوز مساحتها كيلو
مترا مربعا بمبادره من الصليب الاحمر
الدولي ليستقبل الفلسطينيين النازحين من
المدن الشماليه يقطنه اليوم 63 الف لاجئ
وفق بيانات رسميه وتقدر تقارير ان عدد
سكانه الحقيقيه تجاوز مائه الف بعد ان
انضم الى المخيم لاحقا الالاف من
فلسطينيين سوريا تعمل وكاله الامم المتحده
لاغاثه وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
المخيم منذ عام
1952 وتقدم الخدمات لخمسين الفا من قاطنيه
وخدمات لثماني مدارس يعتمد معظم سكانه على
المساعدات لمواجهه فقر المتقع وتهالك
البنيه التحتيه والانتظار السكاني التوتر
الامني لازم المخيم منذ اواخر التسعينيات
القرن الماضي بين فصائل المخيم التي يزيد
عددها على سبعه هي حركه فتح التي تقود
جهاز الامن الوطني المسؤول عن ضمان الامن
في المخيم بالتعاون مع القوى الامنيه
اللبنانيه توجد في المخيم حركات اخرى تصنف
بالاسلاميه هي حركه حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
وعصبه الانصار والحركه الاسلاميه المجاهده
وجند الشام والشباب المسلم وتحدث معظم
المواجهات المسلحه بين جند الشام والشباب
المسلم من جهه والامن الوطني التابع لفتح
فصائل عين الحلوه تتوزع على احياء المخيم
وفق الشكل التالي مناطق البركسات والطير
وبستان القدس ومخيم الطوارئ وجبل الحليب
تتبع لحركه فتح اما احياء السكه والمنشيه
وحطين والصفصاف فتتبع للمجموعات الاسلاميه
وفي منطقه صفوريه تتولى السيطره حركه حماس
والتيار الاصلاحي المنشق عن فتح وعاده ما
تنتهي مواجهات بنتائج داميه مثل التوتر
الاخير الذي اشتعل في نهايه يوليو تموز
2023 وادى الى مقتل 13 شخصا وقبله في عام
2017 عندما قتل 19 شخصا واصيب العشرات في
مواجهات مماثله للمخيم تعقيدات سياسيه
وامنيه بالغه فرغم انه محاط بسبع نقاط
عسكريه لبنانيه من المستبعد ان يتدخل
الجيش اللبناني لضبط الوضع الامني وهناك
من يرى ان الاشتباكات في المخيم هي نتيجه
ازمه مفتعله ترتبط بالاضطرابات التي
تشهدها الضفه الغربيه المحتله هذه
الحسابات تظهر اهميه المخيم الاستراتيجيه
في قضايا تتجاوز فلسطين ولبنان اما في
الداخل فبالنسبه الى كثير من السكان فحتى
لو اختلفت الرايات والتوجهات بين الفصائل
يجب ان يكون الخلاف لخدمه القضيه
الفلسطينيه لا لاعدائها تحيه لاهل المخيم
الطرفين اهلنا واخواتنا وحبايبنا كان
الاسلاميه ولا فتح هدول اولادنا واخواتنا
ايد غريبه عم تعمل قتال ما ينجر وراءك
[موسيقى]